private sector Ohio is being crushed
under the weight of government if we
don't change it you're simply going to
chase more people away from the state
and make it even harder to generate
revenue to pay for government we have
balanced this budget with no smoke and
mirrors and we have done it with a
reform agenda that will put Ohio on a
path to growth the fundamental problem
with the governor's budget bill is it
increases general revenue spending to a
point where it will be the second
largest increase over two year period in
the last 23 years Ohio does not have a
revenue problem Ohio has a spending
problem from 1992 2009 the general
revenue expenditures went up about
forty-one percent and we now can't
afford what we have so we have a new
normal and oh how that we've got to
adjust to the grand bargain that used to
exist where if you work for government
you make less money but you have job
security get a decent pension today the
grand bargain is dead the government
worker makes more than their private
sector peer and in terms of the
retirement they now are exceeding
private sector pay scales and benefits
and that was never part of the bargain
you're talking about a pretty sizable
percentage of the state budget that you
could save if you simply realign
government compensation packages to
those in the private sector in Ohio
we've lost about 600,000 private sector
citizen jobs since 2000 if we cannot get
competitive on our cost structure Ohio
will remain a laggard and will continue
to send our best and brightest to state
south and west our businesses will
continue to flee south and west and
we'll be in Ohio that is a shell of
itself